putin was banking on nato being split
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
president biden at an emergency nato
summit trying to ratchet up pressure on
vladimir putin biden allies announcing
more sanctions against russia but the
president losing his temper when pressed
if he could have done more to prevent
this war
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
the maintenance of sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain do you believe the
action today will have an impact on
making russia change of course in
ukraine that's not what i said you
you're playing a game with me i know the
answer is no we have to demonstrate the
reason i ask for the meeting we have to
stay fully totally thoroughly united
somebody did not get their pudding
as for the fighting ukraine says it blew
up a russian ship and is slowly pushing
back russian forces around kiev
president biden appearing to draw a red
line on what it would take for the u.s
and nato to directly respond to russia
i can't answer that i'm not going to
give you intelligence data number one
number two
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use
so judge i go to you first what does
dana think about the presser
dana has been on television all day and
she's been wonderful i think you should
go to dana right away and then come back
to me if she didn't cover what she
covered earlier i'll fill it in you know
you said something today that i i was
like nodding in agreement because i i
was so i was like why did he answer that
question about 2024 and then the second
part which is was that he lied i mean he
brought up that fine people hoax which
has been debunked over and over then he
says that police officers died on
january 6th
no but anyway you had you he was going
he was okay and then
it was weird so he goes all the way over
there for this emergency meeting i think
it's good that the president went i
think it's good that they have this
unity he said that nato is so unified
and we we are we all get it mr president
we don't need to hear that again unless
something happens then he only takes
like four or five questions and then it
goes to der spiegel now most of you
probably don't read der spiegel you're
familiar with durst beagle right yeah
this is not necessarily the german women
the german paper they are very thorough
they seem to be very interested in
american politics yes and in one
direction right so he takes the question
and the question is about will you run
in 2024 now you could say
look i'm here talking about this 2024 is
a long way off i've already said i'm
going to run again but we'll talk yeah
let's talk about something else instead
he said you know i really had to run and
then he had to go back over and re-trod
retread through all of that ground right
i just wouldn't have done it
i wouldn't have done i would have said
uh i was use that opportunity if you
have the time take one more question on
the relevant points i would not have
done that on foreign soil but it did
okay fine um i also thought that you
have all these reporters they are
completely invested they actually
i think the coverage of the biden
administration in terms of what they are
doing has been pretty good but his
messaging their messaging is so timid
and you are sort of left wanting
what is the mission what are we doing
what do we want to have happen what is
the end goal did you guys discuss that
there's all these things that maybe
we'll learn in the coming days that in
the closed door meetings they had these
discussions but if i were zelinski
i would have watched that press
conferences like okay do you want me to
give the press conference because he
could have answered it a little bit
better um
and i think how'd i do okay great job
you know what one of the rules of dana
parrino's visit to foreign countries is
you go there with the intent of
announcing something of delivering
something what did he say that was
different in fact what he said was so
similar to what he said before he
basically said you know we're going to
respond to chemical weapons depending
upon how much they use i mean it was
just this kind of vapid vacuous
we didn't know what he was talking about
it wasn't like the ronald reagan here's
here's what we got to do we win they
lose or how about this ukraine wins they
lose but at this point it's clear that
ukraine is in a position of getting
russia
russia is stumped right now they're
embarrassed in front of the world they
hit apparently a russian ship in that in
the uh in the sea that's right below uh
kirsan so the question is
how are we going to do this so that
russia backs off
or is the landscape going to be forced
into the idea that look just give russia
what they already have and let's let
bygones be bygones no
ukraine in 94
was told if you give up your your um
your nukes will take care of you we'll
protect you and they never did it and
now zolensky is saying i don't want to
be a part of nato all i want is i want
to be a part of a group the united
states and the ukraine united states the
uk where i'm protected some kind of a
treaty where i'm protected that's all i
want and at this point what we've got to
figure out is this guy's probably going
to win this i think zolensky can
depending upon what we're giving him and
we've got to make a statement to to
putin that you know you're out we've got
to fight you more than you know
depending upon what you do we'll do
something jesse i want to play um some
sound on tape we call that sought in the
tv business
uh it's of uh admiral john kirby talking
about uh how russians aren't
communicating with our administration
roll that
we have tried on numerous occasions to
connect secretary austin with his
counterpart chairman milley the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff has also
tried to connect with his counterpart
we've made multiple uh uh
multiple attempts here uh but they have
not uh they have not answered up they've
declined to take these calls you know
jesse i'd like to quote uh right winger
trevor noah
uh this would never happen under trump
right they answer his calls does this
matter because do we need to talk to to
that side do we know are we getting our
information from somewhere else
there's nothing more humiliating when
the phone call goes straight to
voicemail
whether you're a guy calling a girl
whether you're someone that's in sales
if someone doesn't pick up your call
that is really really bad so yes that's
a problem you know when you do an
interview greg and then after the
interview's over you think oh god why
did i say it like that
that's how biden must be thinking
they asked him and this is where
presidents really get their chance to
make a huge statement
if russia launches a chemical attack
what will the u.s response be
these are the kind of moments that are
made for presidential politics you're in
brussels there's a war russia is about
to do something and biden mumbles
something about uh you know we'll do
something
joe biden speak
that was your moment to shine in europe
to say something that makes everybody
proud and be clear and then they said oh
you know well if zielinski wants to
negotiate some territorial
and he goes you know what
if zolensky wants to let the russians
have the east and that's up to zielinski
i mean what kind of answer is that
you're supposed to say no you're
supposed to have a little backbone there
and then he leaves the press conference
after a minute or two and everyone
starts screaming at him he goes okay one
more question and then he loses his
temper and he said well the sanctions
were never a deterrent i never said that
well everybody else in your
administration said it kamala sullivan
kirby they all said it so they're not on
the same page with that and then he
keeps saying the same thing
nato's unified oh well so what if nato's
unified ukraine's getting swallowed up
whole you could have known ukraine but
as long as nato is unified right right
zalinski could be dead nato is unified
so what this is embarrassing especially
the way he was walking did you see how
they were guiding him like an usher
takes a person to their seat when the
lights start blinking before
intermission like this is the president
united states come on and then he says
well there could be some famine
uh and like we all know there's a
recession coming and now we're talking
about nuclear weapons there's no urgency
there is no urgency to stop this war
he's like i would do a couple more
sanctions we'll sanction this guy we'll
sanction that guy come on this is much
much more intense than he's letting on
yeah you know uh jessica in the green
room you were saying how embarrassed you
were to be an american under joe biden
and i agreed with you
i'm kidding and i'm glad that we
coordinated today uh
character responded jesse could you
argue that biden is trying to portray a
sense of calm
as opposed to urgency maybe that's his
strategy i don't know i could argue that
i could also argue that jesse's
perception of that press conference was
not in sync whatsoever with how i was
viewing the press conference or i think
a lot of americans were and frankly
people all over the world because biden
did have real deliverables he said first
of all out loud i want russia out of the
g20. that's a big deal when you say
russia should be out that's kicking them
out we have a billion in new
humanitarian aid you're we're taking a
hundred thousand refugees apparently i
brought that up yesterday because we've
only taken 11 thus far 100 000 is still
not enough but it's at least clear that
they know that this is a problem there's
another 100 another 320 million for what
they're calling societal resilience to
make sure that the media can keep
functioning that we're supporting lgbtq
people in ukraine et cetera those feel
like real deliverables to me and i wait
except for not wait jessica what are we
going to end the war and on the
on the chemical weapons front i do think
that that is a big moment because if you
think back to one of the biggest
foreign policy blunders of the obama
administration it was the syrian red
line right and and now biden's getting
his own red line and he should delineate
exactly what that is and i understand
there has to be a commensurate response
depending on what he does but i would
like to see and i'm sure boris johnson
the uk prime minister would be fully
enthusiastic about the line actually can
be really really small whatever they do
if there's a chemical weapon on the
ground in ukraine we will respond to the
fullest extent of what nato can do but i
know you want to disagree with me about
something what did he say about chemical
response what did he say do you remember
i don't remember what he said there will
be no response
jessica it was gobbledygook the nature
of our response depends on the nature of
use and the other thing that he said was
the these they're going to give chemical
defense gear chemical defense gear
everything is defense none of it is
by the way how can you refer to the red
line in syria under obama and and uh and
biden i mean that was a joke i literally
said foreign policy blogger i mean
what biden could have said to that
question about chemical weapons and say
he should have said he better not
and leave it at that because that was
also one of the things it's like don't
say all the things you're to do exactly
all right coming up liberal leaders
throwing in the towel when it comes to
dealing with the surge in violent crime
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else